wollen wir nach vorne es geht Dir zu
meinen Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion Fach
und Arbeitskräfte mit zielgerichteten
Maßnahme im Inland gewinnen so heißt der
Antrag dort geht es unter anderem darum
das Fachkräftepotenzial im Inland
auszuschöpfen die hohe
Schulabbrecherquote soll mit
verschiedenen Maßnahmen verändert werden
und weiter fordert die cdu/csu eine
Reform des Arbeitszeitgesetzes die eine
wöchentliche Stadt tägliche
Höchstarbeitszeit im Rahmen flexibler
Arbeitszeitmodelle
ermöglicht und der erste Redner wird
gleich aufgerufen wenn hier ein bisschen
mehr Ruhe reingekommen ist denn das
kennen sie zwischen den verschiedenen
Punkten kommen Abgeordnete die für
diesen Punkt hier reden und vorgesehen
sind andere gehen wieder unter anderem
sehen wir gerade Arbeitsminister
Hubertus Heil eilt herbei
bei diesem Punkt und jetzt der erste
Redner kommt von der CDU CSU Klaus
Wiener
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Fachkräftemangel droht zu einer massiven
Wachstumsbremse für die deutsche
Wirtschaft zu werden schätzungen gehen
davon aus dass unser Wachstumspotenzial
auch aufgrund des Fachkräftemangels in
den nächsten Jahren deutlich schrumpfen
wird damit ist der Fachkräftemangel
neben der Energieversorgung eine der
größten wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderungen unserer Tage wenn das
Produktionspotenzial nur noch auf 0,7
Prozent taxiert wird das kann man so
auch nachlesen in der jüngsten
Gemeinschaftsdiagnose
dann hört sich das zunächst vielleicht
mal harmlos an das ist es aber nicht
denn über einen Zeitraum von zehn Jahren
ist der Verlust den man bekommt
gegenüber einer Welt mit 1,5% Wachstum
das sind 320 Milliarden Euro ich habe
das auch mal in eine Rechnungseinheit
übersetzt die sie alle jetzt ganz gut
kennen das sind 1,5 Albums also viel
Geld
versuche das Fachkräftepotenzial Problem
zu lindern gibt es ja schon länger ich
erinnere zum Beispiel an das Fachkräfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz obwohl in der Sache
ordentlich gemacht funktioniert das mit
der Zuwanderung von Fachkräften immer
noch nicht so richtig hier in
Deutschland Menschen die zu uns kommen
sind oftmals auch wieder weg tatsächlich
ist es so dass jeder zweite der nach
Deutschland einwandert dann auch wieder
Deutschland verlässt ein ernüchternder
Befund wie ich finde und ich kann Ihnen
auch sagen woran das liegt zumindest zu
einem ganz wesentlichen Teil ich habe
selbst mal fünf Jahre im Ausland gelebt
und mit vielen Menschen mit guter
Ausbildung und auch hoher
internationaler Mobilität gesprochen was
wollen diese Menschen wenn sie migrieren
naja ganz einfach sie wollen Geld
verdienen weil sie sich eine Existenz
aufbauen wollen wenn sie aber in
Deutschland ihre erste Gehaltsabrechnung
bekommen dann sind sie geschockt 40 bis
50 Prozent gehen locker bei Ledigen der
Steuerklasse 1 liegt der Selbstbehalt
des Einkommens gerade noch bei 35
Prozent das können sie jedes Jahr beim
Bund der Steuerzahler nachlesen aber
selbst da trotz dieser hohen Belastung
wollen sie ja noch drauf setzen satteln
obwohl in Deutschland doch schon
Fachkräfte oftmals den Spitzensteuersatz
Zahlen so etwas spricht sich schnell rum
und weil es in nahezu einen anderen
Ländern mit denen wir um gute Leute
konkurrieren nicht so ist sind viele
dann auch schnell wieder weg ein
weiteres Problem über das sie auch
gestern schon intensiv debattiert wurde
ist ihr
Paradigmenwechsel in der
Einwanderungspolitik mit dem Spurwechsel
machen sie aus illegale Einwanderung per
Gesetzesbeschluss einfach mal so legale
Einwanderung das allein finde ich aus
rechtsstaatlicher Sicht schon
bemerkenswert noch schlimmer aber ist
noch viel schlimmer aber ist
dass sie gar nicht genau hinsehen damit
was die Menschen die zu uns kommen
wirklich können ich glaube viele von
ihnen haben überhaupt gar keine
Vorstellung davon was
zerspanungstechniker Mechatroniker oder
Heizungsbauer heute so können müssen
haben Sie schon mal von Computer
gesteuerten Dreh und Fräsmaschinen
gehört damit produktiv umzugehen damit
produktiv umzugehen dass lernt man nicht
mal so nebenbei in einem Schnellkurs und
das Beherrschen zu beherrschen brauchen
sie eine gute
Schulausbildung und eine drei bis
dreieinhalbjährige Berufsausbildung und
selbst dann stehen sie noch ganz am
Anfang ihres Könnens ich kann das so ein
bisschen beurteilen weil ich vor meinem
Studium der Volkswirtschaft auch meine
Ausbildung zum Energieanlagen
Elektroniker gemacht habe nein mit dem
Spurwechsel werden sie den
Fachkräftemangel nicht bekämpfen das ist
eine
Illusion
in den kommenden 15 Jahren und diese
Zahlen muss man sich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen in den kommenden 15
Jahren werden knapp 13 Millionen
Babyboomer in Rente gehen das heißt der
Fachkräftemangel der heute schon ein
großes Problem ist droht zu einem noch
viel größeren zu werden deshalb müssen
auch in dieser Frage wirklich alle
Optionen auf den Tisch und dazu gehört
zu allererst natürlich auch dass wir die
im Inland vorhandenen Potenziale heben
denn da ist doch einiges zu heben in
unserem Antrag haben wir formuliert was
zu tun ist ich nenne hier nur einige
Punkte zum einen muss die Zahl der
Schulabbrecher verringert werden 2020
haben rund 45.000 Schülerinnen und
Schüler die Schule ohne Abschluss
verlassen das ist zu viel deshalb muss
die Bundesregierung mit den Ländern
sprechen und daraufhin wirken dass die
Berufsorientierung in den Schulen
verbessert wird auch müssen schulpläne
so ausgestattet werden dass unsere
Schülerinnen und Schüler fit für den
Berufsalltag auch Fliesenleger übrigens
müssen den Satz des Pythagoras kennen
wir müssen auch mehr junge Menschen für
die Handwerksberufe begeistern das gilt
gerade auch für Mädchen ich habe vor ein
paar Monaten die Lossprechung also die
Rede bei der Lossprechung gemacht
Elektroniker bei mir im Wahlkreis von
den insgesamt 50 neuen Gesellen weil
gerade mal eine junge Dame dabei ich
bleibe auch hier ist ein großer Hebel
hinsichtlich der finanziellen
Ausstattung ist es immer noch so dass
die berufliche Bildung deutlich weniger
unterstützt wird als die akademische ich
gebe nur ein Beispiel die Kosten der
überbetrieblichen Ausbildung werden
immer noch zu einem großen Teil von den
Unternehmen selbst getragen und das
trifft dann gerade die kleinen und die
mittleren Unternehmen die hier zur Kasse
gebeten werden ich glaube niemand käme
auf die Idee die akademische Ausbildung
den Großunternehmen in Rechnung zu
stellen und
und
da ich schon die akademische Ausbildung
angesprochen habe wir müssen natürlich
auch Studierende zu Beginn des Studiums
viel enger durch gezielte Programme
begleiten nur so können wir
Studienabbrecher und
studienabbrecherinnen schneller
auffangen mit einer Abbruchquote von 27
Prozent im Jahr 2018 ist auch hier das
Potenzial erheblich wir müssen auch die
Erfahrung der älteren Generation länger
nutzen dazu gehören flexible
Arbeitszeitmodelle und einen flexibles
Renteneintrittsalter an klar nicht jeder
kann jeden Job über das 67 lebensjahr
hinaus machen bei vielen Tätigkeiten
geht das aber und viele Menschen wollen
das auch und damit würden wir übrigens
auch einen der größten sozialpolitischen
Fehler der letzten Legislaturperiode
heilen nämlich die Rente mit 63
es gibt viele Möglichkeiten das
Arbeitskräfte Angebot und Potenzial in
Deutschland zu verbessern von 83
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind
aktuell nur 34 Millionen
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
mit Blick auf die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme ist es unabdingbar
dass wir diese Zahl die er in den Jahren
der CDU-Regierung schon deutlich
gestiegen ist dass wir diese Zahl weiter
nach oben bringen dafür müssen sich aber
von Linken Fantasien wie den Bürgergeld
verabschieden denn damit torpedieren sie
jegliche Anreize zur Arbeitsaufnahme ich
jedenfalls Kriege aus meinem Wahlkreis
nicht aus meinen aber Wahlkreis viele
Briefe von frustrierten Leuten die sagen
ich gehe arbeiten für ein Geld das die
anderen Leuten die Regierung die Ampel
so zur Verfügung stellen will das ist
ein Schlag ins Gesicht das ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht aldera die in unserem
Land habt arbeiten müssen und dafür die
erforderlichen Steuern aufbringen
Handlungsmöglichkeiten
gezeigt sie werden gut beraten diese
Vorschläge aufzugreifen statt ein
drängendes gesellschaftliches und auch
wirtschaftliches Problem mit sachfremden
Themen wie dem Spurwechsel oder der wie
nennen sie das
mehrfachstaatsangehörigkeit zu
vermischen vielen Dank
eine Zahl die in diese Debatte passt
jedes Jahr verlassen etwa 45.000
Jugendliche die Schule ohne einen
Abschluss erreicht zu haben das sind an
die sieben Prozent eines Jahrgangs und
deutlich mehr als vor zehn Jahren
Natalie public jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Musik]
wirklich bemerkenswert welche Themen die
cdu/csu-fraktion nun in der Opposition
für sich entdeckt hat Themen um diese
sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten nicht
wirklich gekümmert haben
die Förderung von Beschäftigung gehört
zum
kernsozialdemokratischer Politik und wir
wollen jeden Menschen die bestmöglichen
Chancen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt bieten das
haben wir unter anderem mit dem
qualifizierungschancengesetz in der
letzten Legislaturperiode getan und das
tun wir auch mit der Reform des
Bürgergelds mit dem aus- und
Weiterbildungsgesetz unter
fachkräftestrategie in diesem Jahr
erst
am Mittwoch hat das Bundeskabinett die
fachkräftestrategie beschlossen und
dabei fünf wesentliche Stellschrauben
zur
Fachkräftegewinnung definiert
erstens wir wollen die berufliche und
die duale Ausbildung stärken um den
Fachkräfte Nachwuchs in Deutschland zu
sichern zweitens wir wollen das
Beschäftigte von heute eine Chance auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt von morgen haben und
dafür fördern wir gezielte Weiterbildung
und Qualifizierung
wir wollen das inländische
Arbeitspotenzial und die
Erwerbsbeteiligung erhöhen das
beinhaltet unter anderem die Förderung
von Vollzeitbeschäftigung bei Frauen
oder mehr Inklusion von Menschen mit
Behinderung auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wir
wollen die Verbesserung der
Arbeitsqualität und der Arbeitskultur
damit Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
lange gesund erwerbsfähig bleiben und
wir wollen mit einem modernen
Einwanderungsrecht Fachkräften Zugang zu
unserem Arbeitsmarkt eröffnet und genau
das hat die Union in den letzten Jahren
blockiert
um dem Fachkräftemangel entgegen zu
wirken braucht es also einen Mix an
unterschiedlichen Maßnahmen und zwei
möchte ich dabei besonders hervorheben
wir modernisieren und stärken die duale
Ausbildung denn für unser Zusammenleben
sind Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker
Bäckerinnen und Becker Verkäuferinnen
Erzieherinnen Erzieher und das
Pflegepersonal essentiell unser Land
lebt von den vielen kleinen und
mittelständischen Betrieben und ihre
Fachkräften und diese Fachkräfte müssen
eben auch ausgebildet werden
vor wenigen Tagen informierte die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit darüber dass in
diesem Herbst noch 75.000 junge Menschen
die eine Ausbildung machen wollen kein
Ausbildungsplatz gefunden haben
2,16 Millionen junge Menschen haben
deutschlandweit keinen Berufsabschluss
und wir können es uns als Gesellschaft
einfach nicht leisten das Potenzial
dieser junge Menschen zu vergeuden
wir wollen die Lehrstellen suchen in die
offenen Lehrstellen bringen dazu erhöhen
wir die ausbildungsmobilität in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern bauen wir
die jugendberufsagenturen aus und
stärken die Berufsberatung und
Berufsorientierung und gleichzeitig
führen wir auch eine Ausbildungsgarantie
ein die allen Jugendlichen den Zugang zu
einer vollqualifizierten
Berufsausbildung ermöglicht
in meinem Wahlkreis dem im hessischen
Karben gibt es das Berufsbildungswerk
Südhessen dort werden Jugendliche mit
besonderem Förderbedarf in
Zusammenarbeit mit den örtlichen
Betrieben und einem hohen Praxisbezug in
31 verschiedenen Ausbildungsberufen
ausgebildet die Vermittlungsquote beim
bbw Südhessen liegt bei über 70 Prozent
und Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich kriege
bis heute Gänsehaut wenn ich an die
Abschlussfeier beim bbw Südhessen
zurückdenke dort standen junge Menschen
an die oft niemand in unserer
Gesellschaft geglaubt haben auf der
Bühne mit ihren Zeugnissen in der Hand
sie waren voll motiviert und Vorfreude
auf das Berufsleben weil ihnen eine
Chance gegeben wurde und genau darum
geht das Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass junge
Menschen mit unserem Land auf der
Strecke bleiben
unsere Arbeitswelt verändert sich neue
Berufsbilder entstehen und andere werden
ersetzt oder fallen Perspektive Weg als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion treten wir dafür
ein dass aus technologischer Innovation
sozialer Fortschritt wird für
langfristige Chancen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt ist dabei die Weiterbildung
und Qualifizierung essentiell wir werden
Deutschland zu einer
weiterbildungsrepublik weiterentwickeln
und das tun wir indem wir zielgerichtete
Qualifizierung fördern indem wir die
Zusammenarbeit der Beruf bundeagentur
für Arbeit und die den Akteurinnen
Doktoren vor Ort stärken und die
individuelle Beratung für die
Beschäftigten fördern das tun wir aber
auch indem wir eine Bildungszeit
einführen mit der beschäftigte sich
während des Erwerbslebens weiterbilden
können weil Bildung eben Zeit braucht
und Weiterbildung nicht an finanziellen
Ressourcen scheitern darf
und das tun wir auch mit dem
qualifizierungsgeld indem wir
unternehmen die von Strukturwandel
betroffen sind dabei unterstützen ihre
Fachkräfte weiter zu qualifizieren und
sie trotz neuer Anforderungen im
Unternehmen zu halten und ihnen aber
auch neue Perspektiven auf dem
regionalen Arbeitsmarkt zu ermöglichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Weg vom
Produktionshelfer zum Maschinenführer
von der Kassiererin zu Erzieherin vom
Elektriker zum Solaranlagen Installateur
das soll keine Seltenheit in unserem
Land sein sondern gelebte Realität und
genau dafür sorgt die Ampelkoalition
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
nächste Rednerin für die afd-fraktion es
geht hier um einen Antrag der
cocsu-fraktion Gewinnung von Fach und
Arbeitskräften im Inland und für die AFD
hat jetzt Gerrit hui das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ein rohstoffarmes Land wie Deutschland
braucht kluge Köpfe und geschickte Hände
da halten wir es für eine gute Sache
dass jetzt endlich einmal einen Antrag
vorgelegt wird in dem Arbeitskräfte
facharbeitskräfte im Inland gewonnen
werden sollen
im Bereich der Schlüsseltechnologien
gibt es einen erheblichen Bedarf an
hochqualifizierten Fachkräften
welche späte Erkenntnis offenbar musste
die Union dafür erst einmal in die
Opposition wechseln und dass sie jetzt
die Regierung auffordert gemeinsam mit
den Ländern einen Pakt zu Reduzierung
der hohen Schulabbrecherquote zu
schließen wird schon ein wenig Grotes
sie stellen doch in sechs Bundesländern
der Ministerpräsidenten da hätten sie
doch längst mit gutem Beispiel
vorangehen können denn neu sind diese
Probleme nicht neben der besonders
immigrantischen Milieus viel zu hohen
Schulabbrecherquote sind auch die
Schulleistungen inzwischen unterirdisch
bereits Drittklässler liegen anderthalb
Jahre in ihren Leistungen zurück jeder
fünfte Neuntklässler kann Texte nicht
Sinn also Sinn erklären kann den Sinn
von Texten nicht verstehen
und in der Mathematik sind wir im Länder
Vergleich auf Platz 33 gelandet einen
Platz vor altbahnen wir müssen uns also
nicht wundern wenn da am Ende zu wenig
Fachkräfte herausrollen das erste was
deswegen passieren muss ist mehr Lehrer
einzustellen der Beruf macht aber den
meisten Lehrern keinen Spaß mehr unsere
Lehrer haben einfach genug von der
ständigen jahrelang Überforderung mit
Vielsprachigkeit Inklusion großen
Klassen und respektlosen Schülern hier
muss die Politik endlich ran
und es braucht auch mehr Geld in der
Bildung gerade auch in der
Grundschulbildung wir hängen dahinter
und vielen Ländern hinterher im
inklusionsantrag gibt es noch eine lange
Liste anderer Maßnahmen die
grundsätzlich richtig sind aber sehr
wenig konkret so dass es wenig Sinn
macht sie jetzt zu kommentieren aber
immerhin die Union ahnt inzwischen wohl
das Einwanderung unsere Probleme nicht
lösen wird weil wir einfach zu
unattraktiv sind um wirkliche Fachkräfte
anzuziehen unsere Nettolöhne für
Hochqualifizierte liegen nur im hinteren
Drittel aller OECD-Länder wegen unserer
abenteuerlich hohen Steuern Abgabenlast
und das medienvermögen junger Leute
zwischen 16 und 34 Jahren liegt bei
knapp zehntausend Euro fast überall in
der EU haben junge Leute mehr in Polen
etwa viermal so viel in Belgien sechsmal
so viel und den Luxemburg fast 14 Mal so
viel warum sollten qualifizierte junge
Menschen nach Deutschland kommen
und damit komme ich zu einem wichtigen
Punkt den die Union leider vergessen hat
die inzwischen extrem
angewachsene Auswanderung sorry
hochqualifizierter deutscher die merken
nämlich inzwischen auch dass in diesem
Land nicht mehr voran kommen können das
haben jüngere Auswanderer letzten Monat
im Magazin Cicero gesagt und sie haben
noch weitere Gründe genannt erstens ein
rigides gesellschaftliches Klima
zweitens politische übergriffigkeiten
bis in die Ängste Privatsphäre und
drittens Beibehaltung der
preistreibenden Energiewende trotz
Inflation
trotz Strom und gasknappheit die frühere
Gewissheit in einem der freisten Länder
der Welt zu leben haben diese junge
Menschen verloren oft wollen sie einfach
nur noch weg
Lea wird es deswegen bei uns nicht denn
für unqualifizierte Einwanderer taugen
wir bekanntlich noch durchaus aber meine
Damen und Herren der Regierungsparteien
die unqualifizierten kommen die
qualifizierten gehen ist es wirklich das
was Sie wollen danke
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Andreas audritsch
der stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende die Grünen hier
heute ganz normal anwesend sie werden
nachher wahrscheinlich weiterfahren nach
Bonn da ist ja der Parteitag der Grünen
den wir bei Phoenix live übertragen
werden heute Abend und da geht es gleich
interessant bis Mitternacht um die
akw-frage also Andreas Aurich jetzt hier
im Parlament mit der Post unterwegs und
habe mir deren Arbeit angeschaut und ich
kann Ihnen sagen dass die postbotinnen
und Postboten in meinem Wahlkreis in
Neukölln mittlerweile extra Straßen
laufen müssen weil es zu wenig Menschen
gibt die dort die Arbeit machen wollen
im Juli 2022 fehlten in fast der Hälfte
aller vom Ifo-Institut befragten
Unternehmen Arbeitskräfte das sind
zentrales Problem mit dem wir umgehen
müssen und deswegen kommt die
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
genau zur richtigen Zeit
wir haben begonnen Deutschland zur
weiterbildungsrepublik zu machen es ist
auch was was sie in den letzten 16
Jahren gerne mal hätten angehen können
und ein zentraler Baustein dafür ist
dass wir mit dem Bürgergeld Hartz IV
überwinden wir richten die
Grundsicherung aus auf Weiterbildung wir
richten sie aus darauf dass Menschen
Chancen kriegen und Zukunft entwickeln
können der Vorrang der Vermittlung in
den nächst schlechtesten Job der wird
abgeschafft dafür gehen wir darauf ein
dass Menschen langfristig qualifiziert
werden dass Menschen langfristig Chancen
kriegen auch Aufstiegschancen kriegen
und genau darum geht es in diesem Gesetz
auch mit Anreizen 150 Euro die man
kriegt wenn man in einen neuen Beruf
hineingeht das sind alles Möglichkeiten
Menschen auf den Weg zu schicken und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir das
Bürgergeld genauso ausgestalten und
jetzt gemeinsam auf den Weg bringen
und Sie liebe Union sie hatten sie
hatten eine Chance und sie reden immer
darüber dass ihnen die Menschen die
arbeiten besonders wichtig sein sie
hatten eine Chance in den letzten
Monaten das unter Beweis zu stellen das
war der Moment als es hier im Plenum um
den Mindestlohn gegangen ist und was
haben sie gemacht sie haben sich der
Zustimmung verweigert sie haben genau an
der Stelle das getan was nicht relevant
wäre jetzt um Menschen zu helfen in
diesen Niedriglohnsektoren Arbeiten
ihnen geht es nicht darum tatsächlich
Arbeit attraktiv zu machen ihnen geht es
nicht darum dass Menschen mehr kriegen
wenn sie im Niedriglohnsektor sind ihnen
geht es einzig und allein um ihren
falschen Populismus und den hier in die
Welt zu wollen das ist das das ist das
was sie wollen und das haben Sie an
dieser Stelle mehr als ausreichend
bewiesen
ein zweiter Punkt zweiter Punkt ist die
Frage Einwanderung und natürlich
brauchen wir Zuwanderung in Deutschland
ich bin froh dass wir Menschen die vor
Putins Krieg geflohen sind eine
Arbeitserlaubnis gegeben haben das
schnell getan haben und dass wir sie
gleichzeitig mit den Jobcentern
zusammengebracht haben das heißt nämlich
dass die Unterstützung kriegen dass die
Informationen kriegen dass sie
Weiterbildung kriegen und das was sie
getan hätten wäre diesen Menschen die
Arbeitserlaubnis zu verweigern es wäre
gewesen dass sie den historischen Fehler
den sie diesem Land über Jahrzehnte
aufgezwungen haben dass sie den
wiedergemacht hätten sie werden in die
gleiche alte Falle getappt es ist
richtig dass diese Menschen arbeiten
können ist es richtig dass dieses tun
weil sie etwas beizutragen haben und ich
weiß dass es ihnen auch an dieser Stelle
schwer fällt Mainz 21 Jahrhundert zu
kommen und dass die den Bezug zur
deutschen Wirtschaft zu
Familienunternehmen zu Industrie völlig
verloren haben gehen sie da mal hin die
brauchen diese Arbeitskräfte ich habe
nur eine Bitte ich habe nur eine bitte
machen sie ihre ideologischen Spielchen
nicht zu Lasten der Unternehmen die
genau diese Leute brauchen die darauf
warten dass die anfangen zu arbeiten sie
halten die Leute weg sie grenzen Leute
aus vom Arbeitsmarkt dass ihre Politik
und die ist nicht zukunftsfähig deswegen
haben sie auch keinen Kontakt an der
Stelle zur Wirtschaft deswegen kann man
diesen Punkten von ihnen einfach
keinerlei Glaubwürdigkeit schenken so
ein ein Punkt am Ende noch eine Gruppe
taucht nämlich fast gar nicht auf und
jetzt müssen sie sehr sehr stark sein
jetzt sage ich Ihnen was was sie was was
sie noch nicht mal zu denken wagen um
mit dem Fachkräftemangel umzugehen
brauchen wir eine feministische
Wirtschaftspolitik es muss endlich zum
Schluss sein damit dass wir den Gender
Pay Gap haben es muss endlich Schluss
sein damit dass wir ein kehrgab haben es
muss endlich Schluss sein mit einem
Steuersystem das Frauen dezidiert zu
Hause hält das was sie über Jahre
programmiert haben all das muss weg
deswegen ist es gut dass wir als
Koalition diese Fragen angehende neue
Politik machen und die
fachkräftestrategie kommt zur rechten
Zeit wir setzen das um und gehen die
Fragen an vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Pascal Meiser
Sprecher für Gewerkschaftspolitik und
dienstleistungspolitik der Linksfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und
Herren es ist sehr aufregend hier ich
halte die Zeit noch mal kurz an vielen
Dank damit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen damit der Redner hier vorne
auch seine volle Aufmerksamkeit bekommen
sie dürfen noch mal beginnen vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ist in der Tat höchste Zeit für eine
langfristige und umfassende
fachkräftestrategie die Lage ist hier
das wissen wir in den Branchen den
Berufen durchaus differenziert
währenddessen einigen Bereichen absehbar
Menschen gibt die Qualifikation haben
die ihnen große Sorgen bereiten ob Sie
auch morgen noch gebraucht werden ob sie
morgen noch einen Job haben gibt es
andere Bereiche in den schon heute
händeringend Fachkräfte gesucht werden
sollen beispielsweise die Klima und
energieeffizienzziele der
Bundesregierung eingehalten werden
braucht es laut IG Metall und der
handwerksverbände allein im
Gebäudesektor über 150.000 zusätzliche
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker die eine
Antwort auf diese Herausforderung gibt
es sicherlich nicht aber mit dem Zögern
und Zaudern der letzten Jahre muss hier
endlich Schluss sein und damit haben
erstens wer sich um qualifizierte
Fachkräfte für die Zukunft sorgt der
muss zunächst einmal für verbesserte
Berufsorientierung ausreichend
ausreichend Ausbildungsplätze und vor
allem auch gute Ausbildungsbedingungen
in den Betrieben kümmern als Fraktion
DIE LINKE begrüßen wir ausdrücklich das
Forum der bundesregungen
Ausbildungsgarantie zu schaffen aber die
Wahrheit liegt bekanntlich auf dem Platz
eine echte Ausbildungsgarantie gibt es
nur mit mehr betrieblichen
Ausbildungsplätzen und einer
solidarischen Finanzierung der
beruflichen Ausbildung über eine
Ausbildungsplatz Umlage die diejenigen
Betriebe unterstützt die tatsächlich
ausbilden und junge Menschen nicht in
zweitklassige außerbetriebliche
Ausbildung abschiebt
und ja wir brauchen da mehr öffentliche
Investitionen in die Berufsschulen und
vielleicht sollten wir auch hier
tatsächlich mal über einen
entsprechenden berufsschulpakt zwischen
Bund und Ländern nachdenken damit auch
die Berufsschulen entsprechend gefördert
werden wie das in anderen Bereichen des
Bildungssystems schon der Fall ist
zweitens der insbesondere die berufliche
Ausbildung attraktiv machen will der
muss auch für attraktive
Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen nicht nur
damit mehr junge Menschen sich für die
Ausbildung entscheiden sondern auch
damit sie nach ihrer Ausbildung auch
tatsächlich im Beruf bleiben das
Versagen der Bundesregierung der letzten
und auch bei der aktuellen ist er ja
nichts besseres zu erkennen für
anständige Arbeitsbedingungen in der
Pflege zu sorgen führt uns die Folgen
der nutze deutlich vor Augen immer mehr
guten qualifizierte Pflegekräfte
verlassen den Beruf oder gehen den
Teilzeit weil sie bestehende Belastungen
nicht mehr aushalten damit muss endlich
Schluss sein meine Damen und
deshalb ist es absolut schädlich wenn
sie von der Union jetzt in ihrem Antrag
längere tägliche Arbeitszeiten fordern
damit würde sich die Arbeitsbedingungen
vieler Menschen verschlechtern und das
Fachkräfteproblem nicht verkleinert
sondern vergrößert meine Damen und
Herren und genauso unsäglich ist ihr
anhaltender Versuch Erwerbslose gegen
Beschäftigte auszuspielen dieses Jahr
auch in dem vorliegenden Antrag wieder
versuchen natürlich ist es richtig dass
ich Arbeit und die Aufnahme einer Arbeit
lohnen muss aber doch nicht indem man
diejenigen die eh kaum etwas haben doch
das existenzminum streitig macht was wir
dringend brauchen sind flächendeckend
Tarifverträge der für sorgen dass Arbeit
auch überall besser und anständig
bezahlt wird meine Damen und Herren
drittens wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
auch diejenigen die ohne Job sind oder
die Angst haben ihren Job zu verlieren
aufgrund der großen Transformation die
wir durchmachen dass die auch
entsprechend Unterstützung bekommen und
entsprechend qualifiziert werden da
braucht es entsprechende Anreize damit
Qualifikation qualifizieren besser
dasteht als irgendein billig-job den man
mal kurzfristig aufnimmt das muss ich
ändern dafür brauchen wir passgenaue
Angebote ein echtes Weiterbildungsgeld
meine Damen und Herren
und
viertens wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
auch diejenigen die in den letzten
Jahren nach Deutschland oder in diesem
Jahr nach Deutschland geflohen sind vor
Krieg elendverfolgung dass die auch
entsprechend unterstützt werden
umfassende Sprachkurse sozusagen und das
nicht als demütiges betteln und
Sprachkurse tatsächlich von Anfang an
umfassen eine schnellere Anerkennung von
Berufsqualifikationen die vorhanden sind
und vor allen Dingen mehr Angebote um
gegebenenfalls
Anpassungsqualifizierungen auch schnell
durchführen zu können ich komme zum
Schluss klar ist auch auf eine wahre
dachstrategie wie sie das von der
Bundesregierung so schön nennen kann man
sich nicht verlassen wir brauchen ein
verbindlichen Masterplan für die
Fachkräfte Sicherung sofort umgesetzt
wird vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle ganz herzlich an diesem
Freitagvormittag und möchte nur noch mal
darauf hinweisen weil mir das auch
gestern schon auffiel fangen Sie bitte
nicht an in die Schlussgerade zu kommen
wenn ihre Redezeit schon überschritten
ist sondern dann sollte möglichst auch
tatsächlich das Ende irgendwie geschafft
sein aber jetzt bekommt erstmal das Wort
Pascal Kober für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin der
Fachkräftemangel ist neben Corona und
der energiekrieg Putins gegen
Deutschland die größte
wohlstandsgefährdung unserer Zeit für
unsere Volkswirtschaft mittlerweile hat
das eine Dimension angenommen das
Forscher und sagen dass der
Fachkräftemangel jährlich 86 Milliarden
Euro an Wirtschaftsleistung kostet und
das ist ein Problem das nicht vom Himmel
gefallen ist sondern dass ich Jahr für
Jahr aufgebaut hat das hat nämlich etwas
mit dem demografischen Wandel zu tun und
nichts ist sicherer als die
demografische Statistik ein Kind was
heute nicht geboren ist ist morgen nicht
auf der Welt sie als Union haben dieses
Thema nicht etwa verschlafen sie haben
es verweigert über Jahre hier eine
Lösung herbeizuführen und das muss hier
an dieser Stelle auch noch mal bemerkt
werden
sie wollen nicht zur Lösung beitragen
weil sie sich einer eigenen Lebenslüge
oder zumindest eines Lebens Irrtums
nicht entledigen können sie wissen ganz
genau dass die Forscher und sagen dass
wir mittlerweile jährlich eine
Zuwanderung von 400.000 Menschen in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt brauchen
qualifizierte Zuwanderung auch die
Arbeitsministerin Ursula von der Leyen
hatte das schon vor zwölf Jahren ihnen
ihre eigenen Fraktion in Stammbuch
geschrieben sie haben sie damals
blockiert wir als FDP hätten damals
schon die richtigen Weichen gestellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
ihr Antrag heute zeigt aber dass sie
noch keinen Schritt weiter sind und das
ist nicht in Ordnung
sie müssen sich der Wahrheit stellen
dass der Fachkräftemangel nur durch
gesteuerte qualifizierte
erwerbsmigration möglich sein kann und
in ihrem Antrag schlagen Sie jetzt
ausschließlich Themen vor die natürlich
den innerer den inneren
Fachkräftepotenzial zu wecken in der
Lage sind gar keine Frage aber wenn man
sich mal die 22 Forderungen Ihres
Antrags anschaut dann stellt man doch
erstaunlich fest mit welchen Maßnahmen
sie daran angehen wollen
Schulabbrecherquote reduzieren
Berufsorientierung an Schulen verbessern
und schulpläne Anpassen außerdem finden
sich in ihrem Antrag Forderungen wie
Bildungsabschlüsse mit anderen
miteinander vergleichbar machen und die
Kinderbetreuung verbessern das sind
alles tolle und richtige Vorschläge
allein die Umsetzung und blieb der
Bundesländer und der Kommunen sie
verschieben die Verantwortung auf andere
dass es zu wenig für eine
Bundestagsfraktion und im übrigen sind
das auch alles nur Appelle ohne
Lösungswege das ist erst recht zu wenig
für junge Bundestagsfraktion es ist
richtig dass wir das
Erwerbspersonenpotenzial des Inlandes
natürlich besser nutzen müssen dass wir
da Vorankommen müssen und das tut ja
auch diese Regierung und jetzt komme ich
zum letzten Vorschlag für eine gute
Oppositionsarbeit lesen Sie auch die
Anträge und die Gesetzentwürfe der
Regierung dann würden sie nämlich sehen
dass wir mit dem neuen Bürgergeld genau
das in Angriff genommen haben dass wir
die Menschen besser qualifizieren um sie
nachhaltig in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union es war ein Versuch
wir warten auf Besserung
Pascal Kober von der FDP hat gesagt es
war ein Versuch und mal sehen was Katrin
Staffler jetzt dazu sagt von der CDU ist
tsu sie Sprecherin der CSU Landesgruppe
für Innovation Bildung und Forschung
[Applaus]
für uns Bildungspolitikern gehört zu den
schönsten Aufgaben und Terminen das wird
zur Abschluss und Abschluss und
freisprechungsfeiern gehen dürfen es ist
unglaublich schön da die jungen Leute
sitzen zu sehen die begierig darauf
warten dass die in ihrem Beruf
durchstarten dass sie endlich anfangen
da damit worauf sie zwei drei Jahre lang
hingearbeitet haben und ich finde es ist
ansteckend das ist ansteckend mit was
für einem Enthusiasmus muss was für ein
Tatendrang die jungen Leute bei diesen
feiern vor einem sitzen und die vollen
Seele bei den Feiern zeigen uns auch
dass es die Fachkräfte von morgen ja
durchaus gibt es sind halt leider zu
wenige ja das System schwächelt und das
nicht erst seit Corona die Bildung die
berufliche Bildung war in der
Vergangenheit immer ein
unterschiedlicher Garant für unseren
wirtschaftlichen Erfolg und genau so
muss es in Zukunft auch
weil und lassen Sie mich das in aller
Deutlichkeit formulieren ohne Fachkräfte
keine Wirtschaft keine florierende
Wirtschaft ohne Fachkräfte keine
gesunden Unternehmen ohne Fachkräfte
keine Energie- und Klimawende und so
weiter und so fort diese Aufzählung wie
sie sich beliebig fortführen
und jetzt sage ich es ihnen ganz ehrlich
ich glaube noch nicht mal dass wir in
der Feststellung im dissent sind aber
genau deswegen habe ich mich die letzten
Monate so gewundert dass so wenig von
dieser Regierung zu diesem Thema kommt
warum weil nämlich die Blaupause für all
die dringend benötigten Maßnahmen die
jetzt auf dem Weg gebracht werden müssen
schon lange auf dem Tisch liegt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie erinnern
sich vielleicht der ein oder andere von
Ihnen wir haben in der letzten
Legislaturperiode gemeinsam ne und
cat-kommission einberufen die
Zukunftsfragen der beruflichen Bildung
thematisiert hat wir haben drei Jahre
lang parteiübergreifend mit
Sachverständigen mit Experten gearbeitet
und wir haben in diesem recht
umfangreichen Werk fast 600 detaillierte
Empfehlungen aufgelistet und zwar
Empfehlungen wie wir in Deutschland
unser berufliches Bildungssystem
zukunftsfest ausbauen können und wie wir
es attraktiver gestalten können
wir haben damit alle gemeinsam dem
aktuellen Gesetzgeber einen
Maßnahmenplan an die Hand gegeben
und das einfache ist das schöne ist er
muss jetzt eigentlich einfach nur noch
umgesetzt werden und wenn ich mir ihre
Reden hier im Plenum zu dieser Debatte
gerade einfach hier zu alle anhören dann
beschleicht mich das Gefühl dass die
allermeisten von ihnen in dem Bericht
nicht mehr wirklich reingeschaut haben
geschweige denn dass sie den Willen
haben die Empfehlungen die wir da
reingeschrieben haben umzusetzen
es geht bei der aus- und Weiterbildung
unserer Fachkräfte um eine komplexe
Aufgabe ja es geht um eine wichtige
Aufgabe ganz sicher es geht um eine
Aufgabe zu deren Bewältigung wir ein
mindest ebenso komplexes und
ineinandergreifendes Maßnahmenpaket
begnötigen das ist also genau das was
man hier drin aufgeschrieben haben ganz
genau das und dieser Aufgabe wird leider
die Ampelkoalition bislang sorry wenn
ich das sage nicht im Ansatz gerecht zu
den zentralen Forderungen die wir
aufgestellt haben zählen zum Beispiel
eine bessere Unterstützung junger
Menschen bei der Berufsorientierung
Umsetzung unterschiedlichster Maßnahmen
zu Attraktivitätssteigerung beruflicher
Ausbildung wie die Stärkung von
überbetrieblicher Ausbildung eine
Exzellenzinitiative für Berufsschule
verbesserte Angebote zur Steigerung der
Mobilität an den deutschen beruflichen
Austauschdienst Maßnahmen für mehr
Transparenz und Vergleichbarkeit von
Bildungsabschlüssen zum Beispiel im DQR
eine Stärkung des lebensbegleitenden
Lernens insbesondere auch für die
Quereinsteiger
und so weiter und so fort könnte ich
noch lang vorher sie sagen alle
wunderbar
Erdem frage ich mich wieso sie ihr
unseren Antrag so schlecht finden das
kommt ihnen nämlich vielleicht bekannt
vor das ist genau das was in unserem
Antrag drin steht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es sind auch die Dinge die wir vor
gerade einmal gut einem Jahr
fraktionsübergreifend und das will ich
an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen
einstimmig auch mit den Stimmen der
Kollegen der SPD den Stimmen der
Kollegen von den Grünen den Stimmen der
FDP beschlossen haben in der und
catbericht und man fragt sich jetzt
ehrlicherweise schon warum sie sich hier
alle hinstellen und erzählen dass das
alles misst wird was wir in dem Antrag
schreiben also liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus den ampelfraktionen
natürlich weisen sie jetzt in der
Debatte darauf hin auf die in dieser
Woche beschlossene fachkräftestrategie
dass sie das ein oder andere ja da
ohnehin umsetzen wollen es gibt da ein
Problem jetzt nehmen wir zum Beispiel
mal das Thema
Exzellenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
im Koalitionsvertrag angekündigt wird in
einem Satz in dieser Strategie von ihnen
erwähnt aber bitte nur Einsätze sind
schon über die Zeit
es gibt allerdings überhaupt keine
konkreten Ausführungen zur
Ausgestaltungen wir brauchen keine
Strategien ohne Plan wie sie umgesetzt
worden da hat der Bäcker nichts davon
der Friseur nicht das Pflegeheim genauso
wenig wie Sie jetzt bitte zum Schluss
Frau Kollegin
das tue ich lassen sie uns nicht an
unausgegorene Strategien Arbeiten packen
sie sind fertig wunderbar danke
Aydan ösus sehr hartnäckig aber in der
Sache hat sie natürlich recht wenn das
Licht gelingt dann heißt das für den
Redner zum Ende zu kommen ich möchte und
das kann ja auch ein bisschen dauern
indem sie bei 0 am Ende sind nicht so
sie sehen ja die Zeit vor sich so wir
versuchen es wieder für die
Sozialdemokratie kommt jetzt Rascha
ist im Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
von der SPD
ich muss zunächst zu den Kollegen Herrn
Dr Wiener und Frau Hue was sagen denn es
ärgert mich schon dass wir über
Fachkräftegewinnung im Inland sprechen
und sie ihre Zeit dafür verwenden gegen
Menschen aus dem Ausland zu hetzen ich
verstehe es nicht warum das immer und
immer wieder passiert gerade der
Spurwechsel gerade der Spurwechsel Herr
Dr Wiener ist richtig ich war
Integrationsbeauftragte im Freiberg
anderthalb Jahre in dieser Zeit habe ich
mehrere Auszubildende in den Betrieben
gab die aus dem Betrieb heraus
abgeschoben worden erklären Sie den
Betrieben noch mal was an dem
Spurwechsel so doof ist das gut
qualifizierte Leute hier rausgeholt
werden das muss nicht sein
wir stehen vor großen Herausforderungen
wenn wir über das Thema Fachkräfte
Sicherung sprechen und wir nehmen uns
der Verantwortung an Menschen Sicherheit
im Wandel zu geben erst am Mittwoch hat
Hubertus Heil in Abstimmung mit einem
zuständigen Ressorts die
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
vorgestellt und dafür möchte ich mich
bedanken denn da stehen sehr viele
wichtige und richtungsweisende Punkte
drin und ich freue mich diese mit ihnen
allen gemeinsam weiter mit Leben zu
füllen ich möchte als erstes betonwerte
Union dass ich ihren Antrag ganz gerne
gelesen habe denn an ihm ließ sich ja
eigentlich ganz gut erkennen dass wir
zumindest an einigen Stellen dass wir
zumindest an einigen Stellen gar nicht
so weit voneinander entfernt sind und es
gibt mir dann doch Hoffnung für die
weiteren Beratungen der
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
zum Beispiel der Aspekt der
Frauenerwerbstätigkeit es ist ein Unding
dass Frauen am Arbeitsmarkt immer noch
so ungleich behandelt werden und viel
öfter in Teilzeit arbeiten weniger
Arbeitsstunden bedeuten kleinere Löhne
bedeuten kleinere Renten und altersarmut
ist besonders bei Frauen ein großes
Problem also müssen wir unter anderem
Infrastruktur aus und ausbauen zum
Beispiel durch bessere flächendeckende
Kinderbetreuung oder Ganztagsschulen für
alle Kinder in ganz Deutschland
wir müssen aber auch dafür sorgen dass
Kinderbetreuung Hausarbeit oder
pflegeeben nicht nur auf den Schultern
der Frauen lastet die Frauen
Erwerbstätigkeit wird nämlich auch dann
weiter steigen wenn diese Aufgaben
endlich partnerschaftlich verteilt sind
es braucht also nicht nur eine
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie für
Mütter sondern eine Vereinbarkeit von
Beruf und Familie für alle
wenn man sich die engpass-berufe genauer
anschaut dann fällt auf das besonders da
Fachkräftemangel herrscht vor
eigengeschlecht über beziehungsweise
unterrepräsentiert ist in den sozialen
Berufen sehen wir überdurchschnittlich
viele Frauen während wir zum Beispiel im
Handwerk sehr sehr viele Männer sehen
dabei bin ich der festen Überzeugung
alles was ein Mann kann kann eine Frau
auch und umgekehrt erst da kann man mal
klatschen
erst vorgestern haben Kolleginnen der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und ich gemeinsam
mit Sozialpartnern und
Arbeitgeberverbänden aus dem Handwerk
zusammengesessen und uns beraten und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben recht
wenn sie sagen dass wir eine breite
Allianz zur Stärkung des Handwerks
brauchen denn gerade dort brauchen wir
die vielen klugen und gut ausgebildeten
Menschen nur mit ihnen werden wir die
Herausforderungen der Verkehrswende der
bauwände oder auch der Digitalisierung
schaffen und das ist mir auch und
besonders für Ostdeutschland richtig
denn bei uns vor Ort wird weniger
ausgebildet dabei ist Ostdeutschland so
ein schöner Landstrich ich kann das
bestätigen wir wollen Unternehmen dabei
unterstützen mit einem
qualifizierungsgeld ihre Fachkräfte
weiter zu qualifizieren zu halten und
sich so besser und breiter aufzustellen
und andererseits geben wir jungen
Menschen mit der Ausbildungsgarantie des
fest offenen guten Ausbildungsplatz in
der Transformation der Arbeitswelt ist
Weiterbildungen wichtiger Faktor und
deshalb freue ich mich dass Hubertus
Heil das Ziel ausgegeben hat die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zur
weiterbildungsrepublik für alle zu
machen
wir wollen zum Beispiel Menschen im SGB
II mit dem weiterbildungsbonus die
Möglichkeit geben sich nachhaltig aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit herauszuarbeiten
und dann wieder in den Arbeitsmarkt
einzusteigen und damit komme ich zu
einem Punktwerte Union in ihrem Antrag
der mir so gar nicht gefällt wir haben
gestern in erster Lesung des
bürgergeldgesetz beraten und da haben
sich schon wieder wie in Punkt 16 Ihres
Antrags nachzulesen gefordert die Zitat
ausgesetzten Sanktionen wegen
Pflichtverletzungen für arbeitsfähige
Bezieher von Grundsicherung umgehend
wieder einzuführen und damit Anreize für
die auf- und Annahme von angebotener
Arbeit wieder zu erhöhen da haben wir
ein ganz anderes Menschenbild ihr
Vertrauen Menschen wir vertrauen
Menschen wir wollen Sie ermutigen und
echte Anreize schaffen und ich bin sehr
sicher dass der Grundsatz Anreiz durch
Bestrafung ausgedient
wir stehen für Ausbildung vor
Aushilfsjob und nachhaltiger Integration
vor sinnloser Vermittlung wir werden
deshalb natürlich keinem Antrag
zustimmen der unter anderem die wir
Aufnahme der ausgesetzten Sanktionen
fordert und eine bitte noch an Sie liebe
Union wir freuen uns sehr über
Vorschläge von ihnen was Einwanderung
aus dem Ausland von Fachkräften angeht
auch das haben sie heute wieder missen
lassen vielen Dank
die Null getroffen zu haben zumindest
kein Widerspruch von der Präsidentin
nächster Redner in der Debatte Enrico
kommming von der AFD er ist Mitglied im
Wirtschaftsausschuss und hat jetzt das
Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren Kollegen liebe Besucher
auf den Tribünen nach 16 Jahren CDU
Merkel und einem Jahr rot-Grün ist es
wahrscheinlich dass wir in Zukunft nicht
mehr über Fachkräftemangel sondern über
Arbeitsstellen Mangel diskutieren werden
und dennoch werden wir in Deutschland
auch in Zukunft jede Fachkraft jeden
Ingenieur jede Krankenschwester und
jeden Tischler brauchen wenn wir aus dem
Totalschaden Deutschland wieder einen
Sportwagen machen wollen
in diesem Zusammenhang freut mich ihr
Antrag der Kollegen von der Union ganz
besonders es freut mich dass sie sich
neuerdings auch für die Förderung
inländischer Fachkräfte interessieren
und nicht nur für insozialsystem
eingewanderte vermeintliche Architekten
und Ärzte
fachkräftezuwanderung so wie sie sie
auch in diesem Antrag hier verstehen ist
ein Irrweg er behebt den
Fachkräftemangel nicht und kostet den
Steuerzahler und abgabenzahler
Milliarden und das meine Damen und
Herren machen wir so nicht mit
was ihr heute fordern ist in vielen
Punkten im übrigen dasselbe was meine
afd-bundestagsfraktion schon vor gut
zwei Jahren im Bundestag hier zur
Abstimmung vorgelegt hat was freilich
von den von dem sozialistischen
einheitswirr war von
rot-grün-gelb und auch schwarz
zurückgewiesen wurde aber was vor zwei
Jahren richtig war ist auch ist es auch
heute noch und so nehmen wir Ihre
Einsicht mit Genugtuung zur Kenntnis
auch wenn sie reichlich spät kommt und
wenn wir schon bei ihren Einsichten sind
liebe Kollegen von der Union dann sorgen
Sie doch mit uns gleich dafür dass die
Beschäftigung einheimischer
Arbeitskräfte wieder der Vorrang
eingeräumt wird streichen wir einfach
die entsprechenden Vorschriften im
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz dann und
erst dann wird Ihr Antrag
zustimmungsfähig wir können uns
rot-grüne weltbeglückungsfantasien
schlicht nicht mehr leisten unser Land
zuerst
ihr Antrag liebe Kollegen bleibt beim
Thema Bürokratie seltsam Waage werden
sie doch konkret schaffen sie zum
Beispiel diese sinnlose
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht endlich
ab und ermöglichen wir es wieder
tausenden Volk qualifizierten
Pflegekräften wieder ihren Job zu machen
und stärken wir die berufliche Bildung
unser duales Ausbildungssystem ist
weltweit geachtet wir brauchen mehr
fertige Meister und weniger gescheiterte
Master
meine Damen und Herren den
Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen heißt den
Mittelstand zu stärken mit ihrer
Energiewende mit ihrer schulden-politik
mit ihrer Währungspolitik haben sie die
Existenz von Millionen von Menschen
gefährdet widmen wir uns mehr denn je
dem einzig wirklichen deutschen Rohstoff
der Bildung und der Ausbildung unserer
inländischen Fachkräfte vielen Dank
[Applaus]
es folgt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Winkelmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister Heil Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger Liebe Union
sie haben sich wie ich Ihren Antrag
entnehmen kann bei uns bei der Ampel
informiert sie haben sich eingewiesen in
konkrete Vorhaben zur fachung
arbeitskräftestrategie aber aus unseren
konkret kommenden Initiativen und
Strategien einen Antrag zu formulieren
mit Punkten die wir ja schon angekündigt
haben teilweise in Angriff nehmen
aufsetzen ist überflüssige Bürokratie
und widerspricht sich gleich direkt mit
ihrer Forderung zum Thema
Entbürokratisierung
sie Listen in ihren Antrag ihre
Versäumnisse aus 16 Jahren Regierung auf
diese Einsicht ist wichtig und gut
einfache Maßnahmen ohne großen
bürokratischen Aufwand
Berufsorientierung und eine aus- und
Weiterbildung die unter anderem
Handwerksbetriebe Industrie und zum
Pflegebereich passt das wird gebraucht
und das liefern wir junge Menschen
müssen Unterstützung bekommen ihre erste
Berufsentscheidung gezielt zu treffen
die zu Ihnen passt aber die
Berufsorientierung muss breiter
aufgestellt sein nicht zu einseitig wie
in ihren Antrag Berufsorientierung heißt
nicht nur an die jungen Menschen
rangehen nein an die ganze Gesellschaft
und unsere Vielfältigkeit und sie
Möglichkeiten somit allen aufzuzeigen
und Menschen
Menschen brauchen gezielte aus- und
Weiterbildung die schaffen wir mit
unserer Maßnahmen gewinnen wir Fach und
Arbeitskräfte gezielt und zwar aus dem
In- und Ausland und ich stelle mir die
Frage ob Sie Ihren Antrag mit ihren
Landesregierungen abgestimmt haben weil
es glaube ich nicht also ich habe ein
lieblingspassage aus ihrem Antrag fehlen
die Fachkräfte werden Windräder nicht
errichten Solaranlagen nicht
installieren Gebäude nicht energetisch
sanieren so wie konnte jetzt den das
passieren sie haben wohl ihre Pläne der
letzten 16 Jahre die Branche der
Erneuerbaren auszubauen und somit für
die Zukunftsbranche schlechthin
qualifiziert die Arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen so geheim gehalten dass sich
selber nicht wussten
hätten sie die Erneuerbaren
vorangebracht die nachhaltigen und
Energiesparen Wohnungsbau gefördert
statt zu stoppen und ja in manchen
Bundesländern sogar komplett zum
Erliegen gebracht wäre unsere
Energieabhängigkeit jetzt eine andere
und Deutschland hätte die Fachkräfte
und hier geht ein schöner Gruß
insbesondere an mein Heimatbundesland
Bayern die Staatsregierung dort
blockiert ja aus bekannten Gründen den
Ausbau zum Beispiel der Windenergie so
aber wir lesen jetzt mal aus ihren
Antrag heraus sie wollen uns hier
unterstützen aber da müssen sie sich
beeilen wir haben hier einen richtig
hohes Tempo eben schon vorgelegt und
warum war es pressiert wir tun das weil
Eile geboten ist
wir haben es im Koalitionsvertrag stehen
und wir werden es umsetzen wir machen
Deutschland zur aus- und
weiterbildungsrepublik die Fachkräfte
von heute und morgen bringen wir auf
einen zukunftsfähigen weg und jetzt
aufgepasst Fach und Arbeitskräfte aus in
und Ausland
wir als Ampel haben schon einiges auf
den Weg gebracht und bringen dieses Jahr
noch einiges auf den Weg und Liebe Union
ihren Antrag braucht man halt dafür
nicht danke schön
für die cdu/csu-fraktion folgt Marc
biadatz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz am Anfang
möchte ich doch was sagen Herr outretsch
sie haben heute etwas falsch gemacht die
Parteitagsrede die sie heute Mittag auf
dem Parteitag der Grünen halten wollen
die haben Sie heute hier schon im
Parlament gehalten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Bundeskanzler Helmut Schmidt hat einmal
richtig gesagt Demokratie besteht aus
Debatte und anschließender Entscheidung
aufgrund der Debatte in ihrer
ampelregierung allerdings sehen wir fast
ausschließlich Debatten und leider nur
zögerliche und viel zu späte
Entscheidungen
und das in einer Zeit in der Deutschland
und Europa vor immensen Herausforderung
steht doch statt entschlossen und
schnell zu handeln verliert sich die
Ampel in koalitionsstreitigkeiten und
ideologischen Debatten diese Folgen
dieser tödlichen ampelpolitik spüren die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Ihrem
Geldbeutel denn überall steigen die
Preise und die Entlastungen lassen auf
sich warten die Gründe für die Inflation
sind vielfältig natürlich sind es vor
allem die steigenden Energiekosten aber
auch die fehlenden Arbeitskräfte
belastende Preise und Wirtschaft die
schlimmste Auswirkung des Mangels an
Fach und Arbeitskräften ist allerdings
wie sehr er unser Land lebt im
Baugewerbe fehlen Facharbeiter um
dringend benötigte Wohnungen zu bauen in
Behörden bleiben Anträge liegen weil
Personal fehlt Heizungsbauer fehlen um
neue Pumpen einzubauen fehlende Fach-
und Arbeitskräfte Schwächen nicht nur
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort sondern auch
unsere Fähigkeit auf Krisen zu reagieren
und diese zu lösen 43 Prozent der
Unternehmen müssen aufgrund der
fehlenden Fach- und Arbeitskräfte ihre
Angebotspalette einschränken oh sogar
Aufträge ablehnen 59 Prozent der
Unternehmen geben sogar an dass der
Fachkräftemangel für Sie eins der
größten Geschäftsrisiken ist als Union
begrüßen wir Liebe Koalition dass die
Bundesregierung sich auf dem Thema auf
dem Weg macht und eine Fachkräfte
Sicherungsstrategie auf die Agenda setzt
das ist gut und richtig so doch leider
sehe ich nicht wie sie mit ihren
bisherigen Vorschlägen in absehbarer
Zeit Abhilfe für diese Belastung unseres
Arbeitsmarkt schaffen wollen statt von
Problemlösungen ist ihre
Arbeitsmarktpolitik gekenn wird von
sozialdemokratischer
Vergangenheitsbewältigung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit dem Bürgergeld den Einstieg in ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
einzuleiten
[Applaus]
zu lud
der Fall machen Arbeit weiter
unattraktiver
sie verabschieden sich vom Prinzip
fordern und fördern und damit von einer
zentralen Stärke unseres Arbeitsmarktes
ihm geht es ausschließlich um
schaufensterpolitik statt konkrete
Hilfen für den Arbeitsmarkt sie sprechen
von dringend benötigen Fachkräften aber
senden völlig gegensätzliche Signale in
unserem heutigen Antrag machen wir Ihnen
konkrete Vorschläge um Fach- und
Arbeitskräfte mit zielgerichteten
Maßnahmen im Inland zu sichern und zu
gewinnen wir hoffen dass diese auch im
Arbeitsministerium gelesen werden dazu
gehören unter anderem die Aktivitäten
zur Vermittlung von Ausbildungsplätzen
auszubauen duale Ausbildung weiterhin
stärker zu fördern indisches
Arbeitspotenzial zu mobilisieren und
weiter an
Weiterbildungsangebote konsequent
auszubauen mit der digitalen
Lernplattform Miller haben wir übrigens
ihnen da auch einen guten Vorschlag
gemacht ich kann Ihnen den gerne auch
mal in nächster Zeit weiter erklären und
meine Damen und Herren doch in keinem
dieser Bereiche schafft die
Bundesregierung eine zu viel
zufriedenstellende Antwort was wir jetzt
brauchen ist ein Arbeitsmarkt der es mit
den Menschen ermöglicht ihre eigene
Zukunft zu gestalten anstatt die
Menschen zu verwalten uns als Union ist
es wichtig wir wollen niemanden
zurücklassen denn liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel sie kommen uns
immer wieder mit 16 Jahren unserer
Regierungszeit doch im Bereich der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik müssen wir
feststellen nie war unser Arbeitsmarkt
so stark und wie stabil wie unter der
Führung der cdu/csu-bundesregierung
wir fordern sie auf kehren die zurück zu
einem vernünftigen Weg und die Erfolge
der Arbeitsmarktpolitik der letzten
Jahre werden auch vielleicht ihre
Erfolge sein herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über einen
Antrag der
cocsu-fraktion Gewinnung von Fach und
Arbeitskräften im Inland Manfred
totenhausen für die FDP hat jetzt das
Wort er ist der handwerkspolitische
Sprecher seiner Fraktion meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich finde es
ja gut dass wir uns in einigen Punkten
tatsächlich auch einig sind und wir
müssen heute heute müssen wir uns um die
aus- und Weiterbildung unserer
fachkräftekräfte kümmern damit wir sie
morgen haben wir brauchen Sie in allen
Bereichen ob als klimawerker
Baufachleute oder als Mitarbeiter im
Gesundheitssystem oder in der Pflege
allein im Handwerk fehlen 250.000
ausgebildete Fachkräfte in den Klima
Gewerken sind es 60.000 diese enorm
Lücken müssen geschlossen werden neben
der neben einer generellen geregelten
Zuwanderung gehört mehr aus- und
Weiterbildung im Inland dazu aber das
Thema ist ja nicht neu das Thema ist ja
nicht der Bundestag hat dazu in weißen
Wahlperiode eine onkette-kommission
einberufen an der ich auch mitarbeiten
durfte und sie hat viele gute Ideen und
Empfehlungen auf dem Weg gebracht die
auch heute eine Bedeutung haben in ihrem
Antrag finde ich dazu sogar einige
Ansätze ich erwähne nur digitale
Lernplattform oder den Aufbau eines
deutschen beruflichen Austauschdienstes
aber beim Lesen Ihrer Wünsche frage ich
mich dennoch ich weiß sie können es
lange nicht mehr hören wer stellt in
diesem Jahr eigentlich 16 Jahre lang die
bundesbildungsministeriumministerin und
wer hat auf den Trend gesetzt dass wir
immer mehr Akademiker brauchen während
gleichzeitig die berufliche Bildung ins
Hintertreffen geraten ist es waren ihre
drei Ministerinnen Liebe Union erst Frau
Karliczek erst Frau Qualität hat am Ende
versucht hier umzusteuern und lieber
Herr Wiener sie haben den Elektro jetzt
ist er weg jetzt hat er hat den
elektro-beruf gelernt er ist immer noch
da gut heute in elektro-beruf ich übe
ihn bis heute aus und Sie werden dann
lieber Elektriker geblieben kann ich
Ihnen nur sagen Vorhaben wir die meine
Damen und Herren vorher haben wir die
existenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
und der Ausbau der Berufsorientierung
werden bereits von der Ampel umgesetzt
andere Projekte finden Sie in einer
umfassenden
fachkräftestrategie die die
Bundesregierung gerade erst auf den Weg
gebracht hat und wenn jetzt nach mir
ginge gibt es bald neben der dem
freiwilligen sozialen Druck und
ökologischen Jahr auch das freiwillige
Jahr in den Klima Gewerken da gibt es
sicher eine hohe Nachfrage und bei
dieser Koalition ist die
fachkräfteentwicklung in guten Händen
ein gutes Beispiel wir waren es die den
Haushaltstitel für die überbetrieblichen
Lehrwerkstätten von 49 Millionen auf 70
Millionen erhört haben erhöht haben
unsere uns ist wichtig sowohl die
Ausbildung attraktiver zu machen als
auch die Ausbildungsbetriebe zu
entlasten die Betriebe finden dabei
nicht nur die unschuldsstützung in den
Fraktionen sondern auch in unserer
Regierung unsere Bildungsministerin
Bettina stark Watzinger steht absolut
hinter der Gleichwertigkeit von
beruflicher und akademischer Bildung
nach bald einem Jahr Ampelkoalition sind
wir auf einem guten Weg den wir
weitergehen werden vielen Dank
ja Mitglieder
ja das machen sie alle jetzt sehr gut
als nächstes folgt für die SPD-Fraktion
Manuel Gerber
ja da hat sich einen vs offensichtlich
durchgesetzt Manuel gawa SPD und wir
sind tatsächlich sehr gut im Zeitplan
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wenn einem
eines der Opposition die Möglichkeit
gibt über die ein oder andere
Errungenschaft aus der
Regierungskoalition zu sprechen ist das
ein gutes Zeichen gerade an einem
Freitag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der cdu/csu ich bin sehr froh dass sie
die Fachkräfte Strategie der
Bundesregierung aufmerksam gelesen haben
an der Stelle herzlichen Dank an
Minister Heil da ist sogar noch viel
mehr drin als in ihrem Antrag zum
Beispiel das neue Bürgergeld und kein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen von dem
ich eben schon das ein oder andere Mal
gehört habe im Januar 2023 tritt das in
Kraft das neue Bürgergeld ist eine
Maßnahme die es Menschen ermöglicht
wieder in Würde und mit neuen
Perspektiven am Arbeitsmarkt bereit zu
stehen eigentlich müssen Sie dem ja
zustimmen zumindest wenn wir mal die
Sanktionen rauslassen geht es da sicher
Möglichkeiten dass sie dem auch
zustimmen können mit dem Bürgergeld
werden Anreize und die Aufnahmen von
besuchsbezogenen Weiterbildungen
verbessert und das durch den
erleichterten Zugang zu aus- und
Weiterbildungsangeboten sowie einem
Weiterbildungsgeld ich finde das ist ein
richtig guter Schritt in die richtige
Richtung darüber hinaus
darüber hinaus ermöglichen wir den
Menschen einen neuen beruflichen Weg zu
gehen und den Faden wieder aufzunehmen
wir wollen mit und nicht gegen die
Menschen arbeiten ihnen keine Steine in
den Weg legen oder sie in kurzfristige
und unsichere Anstellungen hineindrängen
indem sie wenig Perspektive und keine
Möglichkeiten haben sich weiter zu
entwickeln das wäre das verändern ist
richtig gut so
und es ist ja schon lange nicht mehr so
dass man nach der Schule einen Beruf
ergreift und den sein ganzes Leben dann
durchführt eine lebenslange berufliche
Weiterentwicklung wird einem in der
aktuellen und zukünftigen Arbeitswelt
abverlangt unsere Aufgabe ist es die
Menschen gut auf diesen Weg
vorzubereiten eine neue Ausbildung und
somit auch neue Lebensabschnitte
einzugehen das geht in der Schule mit
einem fundierten und zielführenden
Berufsorientierung los und geht bis an
das Ende des arbeitlebens aber auch die
ArbeitgeberInnen Arbeitgeber haben mir
eine Verantwortung ihre Beschäftigten
durch Prävention Weiterbildungsangebote
und Bedingungen für eine altersgerechte
Arbeit zu ermöglichen Attraktivität
einer Arbeitsstelle hört schließlich
nicht beim Gehalt auf auch in den
Unternehmen muss sich Qualifizierung
Fort- und Weiterbildung noch stärker
etablieren
und der zunehmende Druck der auf den
Schultern der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer entlastet ist enorm man
muss flexibler werden verfügbarer
intensiver arbeiten Arbeitszeiten und
Privatleben vermischen immer mehr
ineinander und das macht den Schutz aber
auch die Gesundheitsprävention zu einem
immer größeren und wichtigeren Thema und
wenn Ihnen liebe cdu/csu die Gesundheit
der Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
am Herzen liegt dann würde ich mich
zumindest sehr freuen und ich glaube
auch viele Menschen draußen die hart
arbeiten wenn sie aufhören würden
ständig von Flexibilisierung untergraben
des Arbeitsschutzes zu sprechen indem
sie an der Schraube der
Höchstarbeitszeiten drehen wollen das
ist sicher kein richtiger Schritt um
Fachkräfte zu gewinnen das ist nicht
nachhaltig und damit tun sie auch den
Arbeitnehmern keinen Gefallen mit der
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
werden wir den Fachkräftemangel gezielt
angehen stehen sehr gute Punkte drin
beispielsweise die bessere Koordination
der Weiterbildungsangebote zwischen Bund
und Land steht bei ihnen auch drin
Entwicklungschancen im gesamten
Lebensverlauf fördern bessere
Ausstattung der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
für in der Richtung einer
weiterbildungsplattform und ein
qualifizierungsgeld für Achtung
Unternehmen das müsste sie an dieser
Stelle ja auch freuen Ihre Forderungen
sehe ich damit weitestgehend als erfüllt
im Grunde genommen als übererfüllt an
und ein Thema ist mir auch noch ganz
besonders wichtig meine Kollegin Rascha
nasse hat das auch schon angesprochen um
den Fachkräftemangel zu bewältigen
können wir das nicht nur mit
inlandspotenzial wir brauchen auch
Einwanderung und mit der
einwanderungsstrategie der
Bundesregierung werden wir zur Abmeldung
des Fachkräftemangels erheblich
beitragen Menschen die hier leben und
arbeiten wollen brauchen eine
Perspektive die muss transparent und
zügig erfolgen und diese Menschen müssen
dauerhaft in Deutschland bleiben können
und dafür
und dafür müssen wir das einwanderungs
das Aufenthalts aber auch das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht aus meiner
Sicht dringend modernisieren und
Bürokratie einmal gestalten trinkt
benötigte Fachkräfte fallen schließlich
nicht vom Himmel wir freuen uns über
jeden der zu uns nach Deutschland kommt
ich finde Ihren Antrag zugegebenermaßen
nicht ganz so schlecht ich glaube das
ist auch durchgeklungen da sind ein paar
gute Punkte drinne die in der
fachkräftestrategie ja auch sozusagen
aufgehen dementsprechend auf gute Arbeit
in den Ausschüssen freue mich und ihnen
später ein schönes Wochenende
na das ist doch auch mal ganz erfreulich
wenn man sich untereinander lobt klingt
doch gleich viel schöner an einem
Freitag
sondern Bayram jetzt für die
mindestgrünen sie ist die Opfer im
rechts
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe diesen
Antrag der Union gelesen und habe dann
wirklich die Frage ist das ein Antrag
oder kann das weg denn sie haben dort
Forderungen von uns abgeschrieben
braucht das NÖ wir haben es auch
aufgeschrieben jeder hat es transparent
nachgelesen steht da was neues drin nach
16 Jahren könnte man ja meinen sie sind
mal in sich gegangen und haben
festgestellt was sie falsch oder nicht
gemacht haben und das Schreiben sie
jetzt in diesen Antrag weil sie denken
wir geben unsere Erfahrungen weiter an
eine Regierung die daraus was macht nö
keine Einsicht hinsichtlich ihrer
Versäumnisse auch das steht in dem
Antrag leider nicht drin auch insoweit
kann der Weg ja und drittens was fehlt
da drin eigentlich es fehlt das
Potenzial der Menschen im Inland die
schon da sind und die eben
einen Status haben indem sie wechseln
wollen vom Status Menschen der hier aus
einer Not aus einer Flucht
herausgekommen ist und der Teil unserer
Gesellschaft werden will und sich hier
einbringen will der kommt in ihrem
Antrag überhaupt nicht vor und deswegen
mein Resümee dieser Antrag kann weg und
wir werden ihn auch sofort weg stimmen
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
Beiträge die Beiträge aus der Union
werfen mir eine Frage auf die wirklich
gefährlich ist und ich frag mich auch
warum eigentlich Frau Lindholz heute in
dieser Debatte nicht da ist die sonst in
einer Art und Weise über geflüchtete und
Migranten redet bei der es mir schlecht
wird und da verstellt sich halt wirklich
die Frage meine Damen und Herren von der
Union wollen Sie wirklich das
Deutschland so unattraktiv und schlecht
ist das ist eigentlich nur die AFD
stärkt bitte gehen Sie in sich er liegen
sie nicht der Gefahr dieses Land auf
eine Art und Weise zu gestalten dass wir
unattraktiv werden für Menschen aus dem
Ausland die wir hier hin holen wollen
und für Menschen die schon da sind denen
wir einen Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht geben
wollen meine Damen und Herren
und ich hoffe und das werden weitere
Debatten hier zeigen dass sie der Gefahr
nicht erliegen und dass die
Entschuldigung ihres
Fraktionsvorsitzenden ernst gemeint war
dass sie nicht die Gruppen gegeneinander
ausspielen denn andernfalls kann man
Ihren Antrag auch nicht verstehen warum
da einerseits steht die Menschen sollen
mehr arbeiten andererseits sagen sie die
Frauen sollen auch mehr arbeiten
gleichzeitig kommen die MigrantInnen gar
nicht vor ihr Antrag ist nicht zu Ende
gedacht aber wir reden natürlich gerne
mit Ihnen über unsere Lösungsangebote
und es folgt für die FDP-Fraktion
Friedhelm boginski
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
das irritiert mich immer ein bisschen
also ich möchte eigentlich nicht diese
16 Jahre ständig vorwerfen aber wenn
jemand 16 Jahre Verantwortung gehabt hat
und dann solche Anträge stellt muss er
sich nicht wundern dass wir darauf immer
wieder zurückkommen denn das hat ja so
ein bisschen das Gefühl wie jemand der
nicht Auto fahren kann und ständig
Unfälle baut und sich dann hinterher
hinstellt und sagt ich mache jetzt eine
Fahrschule auf oder ähnliches also da
habe ich schon ein bisschen Problem mit
wir haben
wir haben natürlich riesengroße Probleme
in Deutschland und dazu gehört ohne
Zweifel der Arbeitskräfte mangeln und es
wurde heute schon darauf hingewiesen 80
Milliarden gehen uns durch diese
Wirtschaftsleistung verloren und wir
sind als Ampel auch auf dem Weg und
versuchen Deutschland für die Zukunft
fit zu machen und dazu gehören für uns
drei Säulen das wissen sie auch das ist
einmal die duale Ausbildung
weiterentwickeln der massive Ausbau der
berufsorientierten Weiterbildung und die
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung und wir haben das
klar erkannt und deshalb hat unsere
Ministerin Bettina stark Watzinger mit
den Kollegen heil und Harbeck auch eine
Pressekonferenz
durchgeführt und die
weiterbildungsstrategie noch mal
eindeutig
dargestellt an ihren Antrag fehlen mir
zwei Sachen auf die eine Sache ist schon
sehr intensiv hingewiesen worden das
heißt die Überschrift lautet ja Fach-
und Arbeitskräfte im Inland gewinnen das
heißt also sie blenden die Möglichkeiten
hier durch Zuwanderung von Fachkräften
haben könnten vollkommen aus wir
brauchen pro Jahr 400.000 bis 750.000
Fachkräfte und die werden wir in
Deutschland alleinig gewinnen aber ich
will auf eine zweite Gruppe hinweisen
die mir besonders wichtig ist und wo ich
einfach mich wundere dass sie darauf bis
zum sprechen kommen wir haben in
Deutschland 6,2 Millionen Menschen die
gering literalisiert sind das heißt sie
können weder lesen noch schreiben und
die fallen ja nicht vom Himmel das sind
ja Menschen die sind heute im
erwerbsfähigen Alter das heißt sie sind
durch ein Bildungssystem gegangen dass
ihnen nicht lesen und Schreiben
beigebracht hat das noch mal zur
Erinnerung und ich finde diese Menschen
sind es wert dass wir uns um Sie kümmern
dass wir Ihnen Möglichkeiten bieten in
die Fachkräfte hineinzukommen sich hier
mit einzubringen die finden ja bei ihnen
überhaupt nicht statt und in der Alpha
Dekade sind wir noch mal auf dem Weg
dass die Faktor besser in den Griff zu
bekommen und wir werden als Ampel und
sehr massiv um die Fachkräftesicherung
kümmern wir haben das auf den Weg
gebracht das ist für uns eines der ganz
priorien Ziel die wir haben und ich
denke da brauchen wir ihre Anträge hier
in dem Sinne nicht danke schön
[Applaus]
letzter Redner in dieser Debatte ist kW
Mansouri für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin lieber Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren auf den
Zuschauerbänken und zu Hause ich fühle
mich ja geehrt dass jetzt zum Schluss
der Debatte auch meinetwegen der
Oppositionsführer gekommen ist leider
haben sie verpasst Herr Merz dass der
Erkenntnisgewinn ausgerechnet in ihrer
Fraktion in dieser Debatte gleich null
gewesen ist
sie haben eine Vielzahl von Punkten
aufgelistet die sie anbringen wollen um
den Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen aber
wenn ich mir das mal in der Substanz
anschaue wenn es immer um das Thema
Bildungsgerechtigkeit geht dann höre ich
aus ihren Reihen sozialistische
Bevormundungen bei der
Ausbildungsgarantie sagen sie das
braucht keiner das Bürgergeld das
Qualifizierung und Fortbildung für
Menschen in der Erwerbslosigkeit stärken
soll um dauerhaft in Beschäftigung zu
kommen das verunglimpfen sie als
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen bei
Zuwanderung sagen sie immer pulleffekt
Brücken zu bauen für gut integrierte
Menschen in der Duldung ins
Aufenthaltsrecht da fällt ihnen immer
illegale Einwanderung ein Arbeitszeit
wollen sie deregulieren und den
Arbeitsschutz beschimpfen sie immer als
Bürokratie meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Fachkräfte fallen nicht vom Himmel dafür
muss man etwas tun und das können wir
ihrem Antrag nun wirklich nicht
entnehmen
und es wohnt mich wirklich wenn
ausgerechnet aus ihren Reihen das Thema
Bildungschancen und Schulabbrecherquote
thematisiert wird ich habe mal mit 16
angefangen mich politisch zu engagieren
in der Schülervertretung weil es mir
ungerechte Bildungschancen gegangen ist
und wenn wir uns mal die Situation in
den Schulen anschauen da hängt immer
noch der Bildungserfolg von Kindern
stärker vom Portemonnaie als von ihren
Talenten ab individuelle Förderung zu
stärken das wäre mal ein wirkliches
Instrument gegen Schulabbrecher
und wie ungerechtes in unserem
Bildungssystem zugeht das haben wir
glaube ich unter corona-bedingungen alle
eindrucksvoll gespürt da gäbe es viel zu
tun mit mehr Personal mit besseren lehr-
und Lernbedingungen es gebe darum in
einem so starken Bilanz wie unsere mehr
in Bildung zu investieren und ehrlich
gesagt meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sagen Sie das
doch mal ihren Ministerpräsidenten ein
paar Stellen sie ja noch von der Union
und wenn es um das Thema Zuwanderung
geht
dann geht es darum Sprache und
Integration vom ersten Tag an zu stärken
es geht darum auch ein gesunden
Pragmatismus walten zu lassen für
Menschen die jahrelang hier leben die
gut integriert sind und für die wir
jetzt das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
auflegen wollen da geht es um bis zu
100.000 geduldete die auch eine große
Rolle in unserem Arbeitsmarkt spielen
könnten dafür muss dann anschließend
vieles passieren bei Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen etc und auch da sehen wir
keine Unterstützung auf ihrer Seite
und nicht zuletzt geht es darum dass wir
nicht nur dafür sorgen dass Menschen in
Arbeit kommen sondern dass sie auch
gesund und zufrieden und motiviert in
Arbeit bleiben können bis zur Rente und
das hat viel zu tun mit anständigen
Arbeitsbedingungen das hat viel zu tun
mit Prävention und Gesundheitsförderung
das hat viel zu tun damit dass
Arbeitszeiten eingehalten werden das
Ruhezeiten eingehalten werden das ist
Fortbildungen zum Arbeitsschutz gibt und
das vor allem auch das Thema der
mentalen Gesundheit endlich
enttabuisiert wird alles Punkte die Teil
auch unserer fachkräftestrategie sind
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und vor allem geht es darum gerade in
denen Berufssparten die heute auch
angesprochen worden sind dafür zu sorgen
dass nicht immer mehr Druck die Menschen
krank macht und da müssen wir auch uns
die Personalschlüssel anschauen nicht
nur im Bereich der Pflege der heute
angesprochen worden ist sondern in
vielen anderen sozialen Berufen auch ich
will mal ein konkretes Beispiel bringen
das heute nicht angesprochen wurde der
Bereich der Kitas wo meine Mutter und
viele Erzieherinnen und Erzieher in
dieser Republik Arbeiten einen Bereich
der ein echter Knochenjob ist wo
Menschen gefordert werden wo man eine
hohe Qualifikation braucht und keine
Reichtümer verdient und da macht es
einen Unterschied ob man acht Kinder
betreut oder 15 lassen Sie uns dafür
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen meine
Damen und Herren
und das macht deutlich das Thema der
fachkräftebekämpfung das ist deutlich
komplizierter als hier 20 spiegelstriche
aufzuschreiben ich persönlich glaube
nicht an den Weihnachtsmann ich glaube
auch nicht daran dass es ihnen Ernstes
mit dem Thema der Fachkräfte Sicherung
aber wenn doch dann fühlen sie sich dazu
herzlich eingeladen sich konstruktiv
hier in die Diskussion einzubringen
herzlichen Dank
die Oppositionschef Friedrich Merz war
schon etwas länger da ist vor allen
Dingen auch deshalb bekommen weil er
eben beim nächsten debattenpunkt
sprechen wird doch zunächst hier die
Abstimmung über den Antrag der cdu/csu
35 mit dem Titel Fach- und Arbeitskräfte
mit zielgerichteten Maßnahmen im Inland
gewinnen wer stimmt für den Antrag das
ist die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP wer enthält sich das ist
die afd-fraktion damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt